all right another win on jeopardy for  las vegas braden smith he is now a  three-day champion  and eight for nine on the daily doubles  last night's win  brings his three-day total to 93  800 he is following in the footsteps of  another las vegas champion  james holt tower but brandon is staying  humble about it  he wasn't the greatest of all time but  in my book he's he's certainly up there  and you know him getting six figure wins  each day i haven't even come close to  that i don't think i ever will so  he's he's he's definitely my you know  lodestar but  something that i'll never be able to  reach we'll see if braden can clear a  hundred thousand tonight at seven  right here on channel eight if he does  win tonight he'll be back in two weeks  it's also the final weeks of shows with  alex trebek and brayden we wish him the  very best he is such a bright young man